Uh,
last time,
uh,
I ended by talking about,
about Machiavelli,
uh,
as a both a revolutionary in many ways
and a reformer of the moral vocabulary
about virtue and vice good and evil.
Machiavelli seeks to replace,
to transfer to transpose and older
vocabulary associated both with Plato in
certainly most,
perhaps more importantly
with biblical sources,
wants to transform all
together the language of virtue
to give it a new kind of
meaning to change it from
either platonic or Christian,
other worldliness to a greater
sense of worldly power.
Virtual is for him or to use his term.
Again,
veer too is related with manliness,
with force,
with power.
Uh,
he tells us in chapter 25 of the,
of the prints,
uh,
the ethic of the prints must be one of
audacity and even more audacity and that
famous,
uh,
and,
and very [inaudible] image.
He uses fortunate as a woman and you
must know how the prince must know how to
conquer.
The woman must be used through
policies of force brutality or Udacity.
Uh,
this is the language of Machiavelli.
Virtual,
uh,
is associated with the
quest for worldly glory,
with ambition,
with the desire to um,
uh,
achieve success.
And that's what I want to
talk about at greater length.
Today I want to talk about what in a
political and philosophical literature
about this is called the
problem of dirty hands.
If you want to join the political game,
you must be prepared to
get your hands dirty.
And what Machiavelli means by that,
how he,
uh,
comes to,
comes to this problem
in order,
he argues to affect a
transformation of European morality.
It is,
you know,
their words to teach the prince
as he says in Chapter 15,
how not to be good,
you have to go to the
source of the morality.
You have to go to this source of
morality to effect the maxims,
to affect the standards
that govern our lives.
It is necessary to go to the source
of those standards and those maxims.
And that can only be found in religion.
Oddly,
it seems in some ways religion does not
seem to be a major theme of the Prince,
uh,
in a,
in a memorable passage.
God bless you.
In a memorable passage from chapter 18,
Machiavelli advises the prince always
to cultivate the appearance of religion.
The prints he writes should
appear all mercy or faith,
all honesty,
all humanity in all religion.
He writes,
adding nothing is more necessary to
appear to have this last quality.
Uh,
the point is clear the
appearance of religion,
but by which you clearly
means Christianity is good.
Why are the actual
practice of it is harmful?
Think about the way in
which that transforms,
uh,
what Plato says about justice.
Uh,
in his answer to Glau Conan book,
two of the,
of the republic where,
or Thrasymachus where they both
say it is more important is,
is it not more important to have
the appearance of being just then,
then the reality of it.
And here you see Machiavelli in a way,
adding his voice to that chorus.
It is much better to have the
appearance than the reality of religion.
But in order to understand or to discover
the core of Machiavelli's teachings
about religion,
I have to make a slight detour away
from the prints and to his discourses
unliving and in maybe the most
important chapter of that book,
book two chapter two called concerning
the kinds of people the Romans had to
fight and how obstinately
they defended their freedom.
Long title for a chapter to be sure.
But here Machiavelli developed a
powerful contrast between two opposed in
mutually incompatible moral codes,
the Christian and the Pagan.
If one asks oneself,
Machiavelli writes,
if one asks oneself how it came about,
that people have old people of old and
older in the ancient world were more fond
of liberty than we are today.
I think the answer he says is due to
the same cars that makes men today less
bold than they used to be.
Less bold.
And this is due,
I think,
to the difference between our
education and that of bygone days.
So what precisely is the difference that
Machiavelli refers to here between our
education and the education of
bygone days that makes people,
or that made people in the ancient
world more fond of liberty as he says,
then those of our contemporaries
are Machiavelli's contemporaries.
Machiavelli's emphasis here on education,
particularly moral and religious education
is the key difference between the
ancient times and his own.
These two different ages.
He believes advanced two very different
systems of moral and religious
education.
One based on Pagan worldliness and the
other based on Christian innocence.
And it is that conflict as it were
between what we might call worldliness and
innocence.
That is the car,
uh,
of Machiavelli's a moral code.
Let me quote,
Machiavelli is passage from the discourses
at some length because I think it's
very revealing our religion.
He writes obviously thinking of the
Catholic Christianity of his time,
our religion.
He writes,
his glorified,
humble and contemplative men,
monks,
priests,
uh,
you know,
humble and contemplative men
rather than men of action.
It is assigned as man's
highest good humility,
abnegation and contempt
for mundane things.
Whereas the other that is to
say be ancient moral code.
Whereas the other identified it with
magnanimity bodily strength in everything
that conduces to make men very bold.
And if our religion he says demands
that in you there'd be strength.
What it asks for is the strength to
suffer rather than to do bold things.
In other words,
he says Christian strength,
the strength of the Christian
is the strength to suffer
thinking of Jesus on the
cross rather than to as he puts it,
do bold things.
And it is not for Machiavelli simply
the existence of these two different
moralities that is at
stake by softening morals.
He believes by making us gentler,
uh,
Christianity has had some deeply
perverse effects upon politics.
So he claims this pattern of life.
Machiavelli continues,
appears to have made the world week and
to have handed it over to the prey of
the wicked.
This pattern of life,
this pattern of education,
moral education introduced by the Bible
and Scripture and Christianity has made
the world week.
In other words,
by teaching humility,
self abnegation,
purity of heart.
Christianity has made it difficult
to develop qualities necessary.
For the defense of political liberty.
Christianity has made the world
week or if you want to use his,
again,
highly charged word for that,
it has made the world.
If Feminine Machiavelli would no doubt
be taken up against some board of offense
today for using such a term,
but that's his language.
What can I say?
This is why he concludes there are fewer
republics today then in the time of the
ancients because we do not have the
same love of freedom that they did.
Now,
Machiavelli's explicit,
explicit referencing of the
ancient civil religions,
the ancient Civ off theology is it direct,
is a direct tribute to the role of Numa
Numa and Uma pneuma in Libby's famous
history of the Roman republic,
Justin,
who was an authority on this text,
can tell you more about it if you like,
but in the opening books of Livy,
he tells the story of how Rome was
founded by Romulus who had murdered his
brother Remez.
But after this it required a second
founding and the second founding was the
work of a man named Numa who live.
He writes,
determined that Rome,
which had originally been
established through force of arms,
should be reestablished through
justice laws and proper observances.
In other words,
religion,
in order to complete the
founding of the city,
it was necessary to establish it's God's
and ensure proper respect for the law.
PNEUMO was,
uh,
the bringer of the,
of the Roman,
uh,
legal codes,
respecting religion,
proper observances and the like.
So,
but Machiavelli,
Machiavelli uses living and live in,
in the story about Rome's second founding
to bring home an important lesson
about the utility of religion.
Religion.
He tells the reader is not to be
evaluated by its truth content,
but for its consequences for society.
But the story of Numa or his
use of that story tells us more,
more than just a lesson about
cause social utility of religion.
At the time of the founding of Rome,
Machiavelli writes,
religion was necessary to temper
and control the warlike character,
uh,
of the Romans.
Um,
religion had had to bring
a softening effect upon,
again,
the violent and,
and be steel character of the,
of the early Romans.
But for us today,
Machiavelli writes,
religion has to serve
the opposite purpose.
It must instill something of a fighting
spirit into people who have lost their
instinct to resist
encroachments on their liberty.
I mean,
in many ways,
this is the deeper meaning a of
Machiavelli's one's own arms.
Uh,
he uses in a,
in a variety of passages,
the formula that had good republic
depends upon one's own arms and laws.
And in a deeper sense,
this idea of one's own arms means
developing the capacities to resist
encroachments on your freedom.
The prince,
in other words,
test to use religion to encourage his
subjects to rely upon their own arms
rather than on divine promises.
And that again,
is that teaching of his retelling
of the story of David and Goliath,
the biblical story of David and Goliath.
And chapter 13 of the prints,
you remember how Machiavelli retails
and also rewrites that story.
He tells,
he writes the story saying
that David went armed,
uh,
went,
went into battle with Goliath armed
only he says with a sling and a knife,
a knife.
Those of you who know the story
checked against the biblical
account of the story,
knows that David only went
into battle against Goliath.
Armed with Saul's armor and his sling,
Machiavelli gives him a knife.
Where did this come from?
Why does he add this?
His subtle alteration
of the biblical story.
Okay.
It's hugely revealing.
Its moral seems to be
trust in God's promises.
Yes,
but bring a knife just in case.
It's like the old joke.
You know about the fighter who went into
the ring before going into the ring and
uh,
yes,
the priest to pray for him.
He said,
I'll pray for her,
but if he can punch it,
it'll help
in the smallest respect.
That's,
that's Machiavelli Machiavelli's sense
that his own country was deeply deficient
in these martial virtues,
a necessary to reassert greatness.
And this was a theme of
a lengthy poem he wrote.
Yes.
You'd surprised.
Machiavelli wrote poetry and plays play.
The men Dragila still performed.
But he wrote an interesting poem,
a lengthy poem called
Ambit Siyani ambition,
something like platonic,
most,
which lamented his countrymen.
Countrymen's lack of civic spirit.
And there need to be
reeducated and the art of war.
I only want to read a small
section to you from that poem.
If you attempted
to accuse nature,
if Italy so wary in wounded,
does not produce hard
and bellicose people,
this I say is not sufficient to erase our
cowardice for education can supplement
where nature is deficient.
Stern education made Italy bloom in
ancient days and made her rise and conquer
the entire world and
for herself make room.
But now she lives if tears can be called
life beneath the ruins and unhappy fate
that she has reaped from
her long lack of strife.
Okay,
but now she lives if tears can be called
life beneath the ruins and unhappy
faith that she has reaped
from her long lack of strife.
And just from this little
section of the poem,
you can see that the theme of a new kind
of education and only that can remedy
nature's defects that Mackie,
Ms Machiavelli calls them.
It is this lack of strife,
this long lack of strife
that makes people weak.
People are weakened by prolonged
piece and they are made strong,
fierce,
and independent through war,
only by hardening themselves.
He says,
well,
it'd be possible for Italy as he puts it
to rise and conquer the entire world in
ancient days again,
and made her rise and conquer the
entire world and for herself make room.
His point seems to be this.
If you want liberty,
you have to know how not to be good.
At least as Christianity
has defined goodness,
the Christian virtue of humility,
turning the other cheek,
forgiveness of sins must be rejected if
you want to do good as opposed to just
being good,
you have to learn.
In other words,
how to get your hands dirty.
Between the innocence of the Christian
and the worldliness of Machiavelli's new
morality,
there can be no reconciliation.
These are just two incompatible moral
positions that Machiavelli states,
but he goes further than this.
The safety and security
enjoyed by the innocent,
enjoyed by the innocence,
our freedom to live blameless lives and
to have untroubled sleep depends upon
the princess clear eyed and
even ruthless use of power.
The true statesman,
the true prints for Machiavelli must
be prepared to mix a love of the common
good,
a love of his own people with a streak
of cruelty that is often regarded as
essential for a great ruler in general.
In another part of knowing
how not to be good,
knowing when and how to use cruelty
or what Machiavelli telling me calls
cruelty,
well-used.
It's well used.
It's a virtue.
This is simply another example of how
moral goodness grows out of an even
requires a context of moral evil.
Machiavelli's advice to you is clear.
If you cannot accept the
responsibilities of political life,
if you cannot afford to
get your hands dirty,
if you cannot accept the harsh
necessities that may require cruelty,
deceit,
and even murder,
then get out of the way,
and this is not for you.
Don't seem to impose,
don't seek to impose your
own high minded innocence,
sometimes called justice,
your own highminded innocence.
On the requirements of state craft
because it will only lead to ruin
in the modern era.
The presidency of Jimmy Carter,
for example,
uh,
it's usually taken as exhibit a
of the confusion between Christian
humanitarianism and the necessities
of raising reason of state.
You can't do the tough thing if
you can't do the harsh thing.
Machiavelli says,
then stay out of politics
and don't attempt to impose your
high minded morality on the state.
In,
as I said at the beginning in
the philosophical literature,
this has become known as the
problem with dirty hands.
So named after a famous play written by
the French philosopher John Paul Sartre,
the problem of dirty hands
refers to the conflict of duties.
Again,
conflict of moralities between the
harsh requirements of politics and the
equally demanding desire for moral
purity to keep the world at a distance.
Machiavelli doesn't deny that there is
something deeply admirable about the
desire to remain morally pure,
morally decent,
morally innocent,
but he just wants to say this is a very
different morality from the morality of
politics.
In Sartre's play.
Uh,
the action takes place in a fictional
eastern European country during World War
II.
Probably something like Yugoslavia
were a communist resistance fighter.
Reproaches an idealistic young recruit
to the resistance who is resisting is
barking at the order to carry
out a political assassination.
Why did you join us?
The communist resistance fighter asks
purity as an idea for the Yogi or the
monk.
Do you think anyone can govern innocently.
Okay.
Do you think anyone can govern innocently?
The phrase taken of course,
from San juiced,
the,
the one of the leaders of the Jacobin
reign of terror in the French level during
the French revolution.
What do you think,
what do you think politics is?
You know,
a game of moral purity.
The same kind of conflict,
uh,
is really very much at the car,
of the great political fiction,
uh,
of John Le Carre.
Uh,
the great,
uh,
you know,
novelist of the,
of the Cold War and the,
and so on and in,
in,
in his great,
uh,
one of his early political thrillers,
a book called the spy who
came in from the cold.
He depicts,
they're a British agent
who was working undercover,
uh,
and who at the same time as carrying on
a love affair with an idealistic young
English librarian who has
joined the Communist Party,
in this case a sh she,
the communist is the,
is the idealistic one.
She's joined the party because it will,
she believes it will aid the cause of
nuclear disarmament and we'll bring
international peace.
And when Lima's the spy a
reveals to her that he is a spy,
he tells her his view of what politics
is really the nature of politics.
There's only one law in the game.
Uh,
Lima says the expediency
of temporary alliances,
the expediency of temporary alliances.
Who Do you think spies are?
Priests.
Saints.
Martyrs.
There's squall,
a little men,
fools,
queers,
sadists,
drunkards,
people who play cowboys and Indians
to brighten their rotten lives.
You think they sit like monks
weighing up right and wrong.
So both of these cases,
the Satya case,
the John Le Carre case in a way,
uh,
are interesting,
but they're also sort of cases of what
I think of his full machiavellianism,
uh,
kind of foam intellectuals
engaging in tough talk,
uh,
to show that they have
really lost their innocence,
which is the sort of,
you know,
intellectual,
uh,
equivalent of,
of,
of losing your virginity.
You know,
showing you're not,
you're not really
innocent about the world.
Machiavelli,
of course,
likes to play that game and it suggests
that the world is divided between the
weak and the strong between the realists
who see things the way they are and the
idealists who require the
comfort of moral illusions.
Uh,
yes,
Machiavelli's sometimes seems to
corroborate this point of view.
Does he not say that
armed profits always win?
The unarmed profits lose?
Did he not?
Right.
Did he,
did he not say that he wrote to reveal
the effectual truth of things and not
just what people have
imagined the case to be?
Yet it seems inconceivable
that Machiavelli wrote an
entire book simply to prove
the obvious.
That is to say that the strong will
always crush the week and that politics is
left to those who leave their scruples,
uh,
at the door.
Yeah.
The question is,
was Machiavellian,
was Machiavelli really
that kind of Machiavellian?
Was Machiavelli a Machiavellian?
Let's,
let's see.
What kind of government
did Machiavelli think best
as he indicates at the
beginning of the prince,
there are two kinds of regimes.
There are principalities and republics,
but each of these regimes he says is
based on certain contrasting dispositions
or what he calls humors,
humors.
You,
Maury humors in every society he writes,
this is chapter nine of the prints in
every society to diverse humors are found
from which this arise that the people
desire neither to be commanded nor
oppressed by the great and the great
desire to command and oppress the people.
These are the two great political,
psychological dispositions,
the popular desire not to be oppressed
and the disposition of what he calls the
great uh,
to command and oppress.
Machiavelli uses these two psychological
and even in some ways cuase I medical
terms humors to designate two classes of
people on which every society is based.
His theory of the humors in chapter
nine seems in some ways to be rep
reminiscent of Plato's account of the
three classes of the soul or the three
parts of the soul with
one vivid exception.
Each class of the city he says,
is bound or determined by a humor,
but neither humor is anchored
in reason or rationality.
Every state is divided into two
classes expressing these two qualities,
these two psychological qualities,
the Grandy,
the rich and powerful,
who wished to dominate and the popular,
the common people who wish
merely to be left alone,
who wish neither to be
route to rule nor be ruled.
Now,
one might expect that the author of a
book entitled the prints would favor the
great,
would favor the grand [inaudible].
Those who desire to rule our,
these are not these aristocratic
goals of honor and glory.
Precisely what Machiavelli
seems to be advocating,
okay.
Yet in many ways,
Machiavelli proceeds to deprecate
the virtues of the nobility.
Okay.
Perhaps to our surprise,
the ends of the people,
the ends,
the purposes of the people is more decent
than that of the great since the great
one to oppress and the people
want not to be oppressed.
He says
his advice is that the prince should seek
to build his power base on the people
rather than on the nobles because
of their ambition for power.
The nobles will always be a threat to
the prince and an interesting reversal of
the platonic and Aristotelian
conception of politics.
It is the nobles here who are said to
be the more fickle and unpredictable,
while the people are more
constant and reliable.
Remember in the platonic and
Aristotelian view of politics,
the democracy that rule of the people,
the Deimos was always criticized for it
being fickle and unstable and subject to
whim and passion and so on.
Here in Machiavelli tells us to just the
great who are subject to this kind of
inconstancy and the
people are more reliable.
The worst,
the worst he writes to
the prince can accept,
expect from a hostile people
is to be abandoned by them.
But from the great,
when they are hostile,
he must fear not only being abandoned,
but also that they may move against him.
The pop,
the
Grandy are more dangerous and fickle.
So the main business of government
consists and knowing how to control the
elites because they are always a
potential source of conflict and ambition.
The prince must know how to chase in the
ambition to humble the pride as it were
of the great and powerful.
And this we will see,
uh,
as early as Wednesday becomes a major
theme in the philosophy of Thomas Hobbes,
humbling or chastening
the pride of the few.
The rule of the prints are sovereign
requires the ability to control the
ambition and to do so through selective
policies of executions of public
accusations and political trials.
Remember the example that we read,
uh,
at the end of class on Friday,
I believe from chapter seven,
the example of Cesare
Borgia and Ramiro d Marco,
and how his execution,
his bloody execution left the people.
Machiavelli says stupefied and satisfied
here is a perfect example of how to
control the ambitions of the
nobles into when the people,
uh,
to your side.
So Machiavelli's Prince Wa,
well,
not exactly a Democrat,
uh,
recognizes the essential decency of the
people and the need to keep their faith.
And by decency he seems to
mean their absence of ambition,
the absence of the desire
to dominate and control.
But this kind of decency is
not the same as goodness.
For there is also a tendency on the
part of the people to descend into what
Machiavelli calls idleness or license.
The desire not to oppress
others may be decent,
but at the same time that people have
to be taught or educated how to defend
their liberty.
1500 years of Christianity,
he says,
have left people weak,
have left the people week without
their capacities to exercise political
responsibility and the resources
to defend themselves from attack.
So just as princess must know how to
control the ambitions of the multitude,
uh,
how to control the
ambitions of the nobles.
Excuse me.
They,
the prince is must know how to strengthen
the desires of the common people.
Some readers of the prints,
even some very astute readers of the
prince has thought that Machiavelli's work
is really,
or Machiavelli's prince is really a kind
of Democrat in disguise and that the
prince is intended precisely to alert
the people to the dangers of a use of a
user pay.
Terry prints,
this is for example what the great 17th
century political philosopher Spinoza
believed about Machiavelli in his book
called the political simply called the
political treatise Spinosa road.
Machiavelli wished to show how how
careful of people should be before
interesting its welfare
to a single prince.
I am led.
Spinosa continues to this
opinion concerning that most
far seeing man because it
is known that he was favorable to liberty,
that spinosa on machiavellian because
it was favor he was favorable to liberty
and that the book he says,
it's kind of a satire on princely
rule or if you don't believe Spinosa,
if you don't believe his
authority is sufficient,
consider someone who you'll be
reading in a couple of weeks.
John,
Jack Roussel from this social contract,
Machiavelli was an honorable
man and a good citizen.
Rousseau says,
an honorable man and a good citizen who
being attached to the house of medicine.
[inaudible] was forced during
the oppression of his homeland,
disguise his love of freedom
so that the prince was written in a way
that disguise the real teaching of the
book,
which is the love of,
of freedom and presumably
the freedom of the people.
Something of the type that
Rousseau himself spoke about.
Maybe these comments go too far.
I mean,
maybe they are exaggerations and I,
I think to some degree they are.
But it's revealing at both of these very
serious readers of Machiavelli took him
to be an apostle of freedom.
Spinosa taking him,
taking his book to be a warning to the
people about the dangers of princely
rule.
Roussel believing that he had deliberately
disguised his love of freedom because
he had to appeal to the
tyrannical nature of the,
of the Medici family.
In either case,
they regard him as surreptitiously
taking the side of the people against the
nobles.
In any case,
whatever one makes up those examples.
Uh,
Machiavelli seems to be challenging
important aspects of the classical
conceptions that we've been talking
about up to this point in the classical
republic for the ancient
republic of Plato and Aristotle.
This repo,
this,
these republics were ruled by Nobilities,
uh,
gentlemen possessed of wealth and leisure
who were therefore capable of forming
sound political judgment.
Who will dominate well,
in Machiavelli's state,
it is the people who are going to be
the dominant social and political power.
Machiavelli wants to redirect power to
some degree away from the nobles and
toward the people.
One wants to know why.
Why does he want to do
that in the first place?
He judges the people to be
more reliable as he tells us.
Then the great once the people have
been taught to value their liberty,
have learned to oppose encroachments on
their freedom to be fierce in vigilant.
Watch dogs read it in humble
and subservient underlings,
they will serve as a reliable basis
for the greatness and power of a state.
With the people on his side,
the prince is more likely to achieve
his goals of a robust civil life for his
people and eternal glory for himself.
And does.
Machiavelli likes to say the prince
must know how to adapt to the times.
What is true for princes is no less
true for advisors to princes like
Machiavelli himself.
One must know the times and character
of a people and the ancient republic.
It may have been necessary
to find restraints on the
pat to defined and imposed
restraints and the passions of the Deimos.
But in the modern world he says,
we're republics of become
a thing of the past.
The people need to be taught how to
value their liberty above all else,
the most excellent princes of
the past were those like Moses.
He tells us who brought tables of law
and prepared people for self government.
It is fitting and proper that the
prince concludes the last chapter.
Chapter 26 concludes with a patriotic
call to his countrymen to emancipate
themselves and liberate
Italy from foreign invaders.
So what did Machiavelli achieve?
What were his actual accomplishments?
Did he accomplish all he set out to do,
to rewrite or to write a new moral
code for political life to found a new
political continent as he speaks about
just fine to found new modes and orders a
along the lines of Columbus.
Did he achieve this one?
First of all,
one should not and cannot underestimate
his unprecedented break with both
classical and biblical antiquity
more than anyone else before him and
perhaps more than anyone else since he
sought to liberate politics
from ecclesiastical control.
The new prints is we've seen
must know how to use religion,
but,
but needs to learn how not
to be used by religion.
Must not become a dupe of the religious.
He must know how to use religious
passions and sentiments,
but not be used by them.
Politics must become a
purely worldly affair.
It should not be limited or constrained
by any transcendent standards or moral
laws that do not derive
from politics itself.
Why there a law of God or some kind
of transcendent moral order or code?
Machiavelli's warning,
we might say today to the religious right?
Yeah.
Res Critique of the
religious right cannot be,
cannot make politics conform
to a transcendent moral law.
But not only did Machiavelli bring
a new worldliness to politics,
he also introduced a new kind of populism.
You might say,
Plato and Aristotle imagined aristocratic
republics that would invest power in
an aristocracy of education and virtue.
Machiavelli deliberately seeks to
enlist the power of the people,
uh,
grants the grant against
aristocracies of education in virtue,
he is a kind of pro Democrat almost who
sought to recreate not through accident
and chance,
but to planning and design
a new kind of republic.
In the modern world,
there are public that Machiavelli imagined
and it's interesting while he tells
us he's only going to the effectual truth
of things and not the imagination of
it.
Nevertheless,
and Machiavelli does himself
imagine a new kind of regime,
a new kind of republic in the modern
world that would not be a city at peace,
but would be a city at war.
It would be armed and expansive.
Machiavelli's republic feeds on
conflict and war and conquest.
It is aggressive and imperialistic,
does it sound familiar?
Is it us?
In fact,
if you look at a brilliant article,
I think in this week's new republic
by Robert Kagan called Cowboy nation,
Kagan demonstrates,
I think with a great deal of conviction
that the American republic from its
onset has been expansive,
aggressive imperialistic family
conquest of the territory's,
the expropriation of the native Americans,
the acquisition of Louisiana,
wars of liberation
against Mexico and Spain,
and so on,
well into the,
into the 20th and now the
21st century in aggressive,
expansive imperialistic republic that
he says has been our history and what it
should say.
What it doesn't quite say,
I think is that this,
it has been this history,
not because it is American,
but because it is a republic
because of its regime type.
It's regime character.
That kind of behavior seems perhaps to
be built in to the natures of republic.
It was Machiavelli's admiration for the
politics with someone once called the
lupine politics,
though wolf like politics of,
of Republican,
wrong,
that led him to understand that
all social and moral goods,
uh,
have been established by
morally questionable means.
Have we become or have we always
been Machiavelli's republic?
Machiavelli's desire.
Think about that.
When you're in your sections
are writing your papers
and you will get those
paper topics on by the way.
And finally,
Machiavelli is the author of the new,
a moral realism
by whatever means necessary,
I think is his motto or should be his
model by whatever means necessary.
And I believe he claims to
be merely stating out loud,
merely stating,
allowed what all writers
have known all along.
Bless you.
It is necessary.
He says,
for the prince to know well how
to use the beast and the man
he writes,
this role,
he says,
was taught covertly by ancient writers.
It was taught covertly by ancient writers.
He says in chapter 18 the idea then
that Machiavelli is doing no more than
saying openly and overtly what ancient
writers had wrapped in parable and enigma
in myth says something about
Machiavelli's new political science,
what was previously taught only subtly
and in private will now be taught openly
and in public.
What was once available only to a
few will now be available to all,
perhaps more than anything else.
Machiavelli's new openness
is readiness to challenge,
received authority,
and his willingness to consider authority
is self created as self made rather
than bestowed by either nature or grace
is what fundamentally constitutes his
modernity.
So I'm going to leave it on that note.
And on Wednesday we will begin the study
of one of Machiavelli's greatest and
most profound disciples
in the modern world.
A man by the name of Thomas Hobbes.